baby Stockholm offers a completely
unique approach to accommodating your
Workforce this promotional video shows
off what the government hopes will be
its answer to the migration issue over
200 bedrooms with ensuites a bar and a
gym all on a barge that could be moored
here on Portland home of the Jurassic
Coast
so that would suffer and home two to
Sally and her locals who are wary of the
idea Portland's always been so laid back
I think they've chosen it as an easy
option but I think you'll find you're
going to have a big uproar against this
two doctors surgeries here we cut those
of us who live here now can't get an
appointment for over two weeks Mickey
and Wayne agree that local services are
stretched they've lived here all their
lives and say there's not enough to go
around we just don't want it here really
a lot of the locals All Humans aren't
being treated equally
the locals wherever these people are
going have been completely forgotten
about the homeless are being forgotten
about
first time that Portland Harbor has
housed static floating accommodation up
until 2005 the prison hmp Weir was
docked here now there's a very real
possibility that this island could
become home to hundreds of Asylum
Seekers
which the local MP says could discourage
tourism to an area that depends on it he
says specially built facilities in urban
areas could be the answer
land-based reception centers are going
to have to be built whether we like it
or not yes it's going to cost money but
I suspect in the in the longer term
it'll cost less than what we're doing
now which is Hotel ships barges etc etc
he is considering legal action like
those opposing Lincolnshire military
base ref scampton being turned into
temporary accommodation but the
government says these are realistic
Solutions well there's a cost of about
six million pounds a day that we are
spending on accommodation for people in
this country who are going through that
process and the immigration Minister
Robert generic set out last week about
how we're looking for quite a lot of
former military bases or other similar
sites but is also actively considering
what can be done with some of these
floating vessels
Charities supporting those seeking
asylums say both barges and military
bases are inadequate to those seeking
Sanctuary but soon a place that has
previously been the pride of Britain may
need to play a part in a different
challenge for the nation
in Dorset